il existe un piège pour gagner la dame
avec les Blancs contre la Sicilienne en
moins de 10 coups je l'ai placé pour la
première fois à seulement 11 ans au
championat de France jeune dans une
partie super importante dans les
premières tables à l'époque pour se
préparer il faut savoir qu'il n'y avait
pas les ordinateurs il fallait le matin
avant la ronde aller gratter les
feuilles de parties souvent illisibles
nos adversaires les recopier à la main
puis les montrer à nos entraîneurs pour
qu'ils trouvent éventuellement une
faille et ce jour-là vous allez voir que
mon entraîneur a trouvé un gros trou
dans les parties de mon adversaire qui
est tombé en dans le panneau ce jour-là
en plus mon père qui me suivait depuis
les gradins avec des jumelles les avait
oublié à la maison et le temps qu'il
fasse l'allerretour au git et qu'il
revienne ma partie était déjà terminée
il a halluciné dans cette position les
Noirs jouent donc G6 pour faire une
espèce de dragon et là on fait cavalier
prend C6 B prend C6 E5 et ici je
m'attendais pas à ce que mon adversaire
fasse des prend E5 il voulait sûrement
que j'échange les dames sauf que là fou
prend F7 roi prend F7 c'est le Magnus
Smith trap et c'est cadeau une dame
gratuite